we're exponentially getting sicker bad
or more depressed more infertile every
institution in the healthcare industry
they profit from people being sick and
they've been silent on why we're getting
sick which is food what Coke does is
they get a bunch of consultants in the
room and they have a Playbook and the
Playbook revolves around how do we rig
how do we pay off how do we weaponize
institutions of trust so a couple weeks
ago you had a 60 Minutes special on
Obesity the doctor Dr Fatima Stanford
from Harvard on that special said that
obesity is genetic but the number one
cause of obesity is genetics she
literally said that your choices and
lifestyle and what you eat and how much
movement you have does not have a large
impact on Obesity why it's genetic and
it's an urgent imperative that parents
don't really question or stigmatize what
their kid is eating but need a
pharmaceutical injection are these
people dumb or are they being malicious
or like what's going on I believe that
the greatest lie the American people are
being told is that all right guys Bang
Bang got Cali here with me uh you had
this Mega viral tweet thread uh
basically just saying that all the
incentives in the food beverage and
pharmaceutical industry is completely
off uh people say that for a long time
but you're messaging specifically
resonated because of your experience
what is going on
so here's what I think happened we're
all getting sick right we're
exponentially getting sicker fat or more
depressed more infertile autoimmune
conditions are up allergies are up
childhood obesity is up all these things
are randomly up and I think it's clear
to everyone it's tied to food and I
think the the devil's bargain with the
healthcare industry is that every
institution in the healthcare industry
from Pharma to your doctor to Med
schools they profit from people being
sick and they've been silent on why
we're getting sick which is food so I
think people implicitly feel that I
think there's clearly something off when
you look at a kid's classroom and 50 of
five-year-olds are overweight or obese
now according to the CDC 50 50 during
covid of of folks between 5 and 12 and
um and just as a new parent I know
you're you're a real you know you have a
one-year-old too
it's just uh there's something very
concerning I think viscerally and what I
think this tweet tapped into is that now
I'm working to change these incentives
earlier in my career
I saw inside the room so I was you know
good young conservative guy I worked in
politics worked on campaigns inevitably
uh folks from the left and the right
inevitably are across the table from
special interests you go into Consulting
and I worked for both soda uh companies
and Pharma companies so I can go in a
little bit with the soda companies I
think is the funny part because when
people hear that it's like big soda
right like what what exactly does it
mean to work with the soda companies yes
they work I'll go exactly into the
Playbook so I worked for uh the American
Beverage Association in 2011 2012. okay
and they all hide behind these front
groups and specifically what they were
trying to do in 2011 2012 is keep soda
in food stamp spending so food stamps
are the number one nutritional program
for lower income folks 15 of Americans
depend on it 110 billion dollars is
spent on it and the number one item
purchased is soda really 70 of all food
stamps men go to processed food but 10
go to sugar water diabetes water and if
you look at any scientific study on like
what's really contributed to obesity and
diabetes and this this chronic disease
crisis we're in it's this weaponized
sugar in liquid form has really led to
that and that's 10 of all food stamps
being so people are questioning this
obviously it makes no sense it's it's
criminal public policy because we're
giving our country you know obesity
diabetes and then paying for that
trillions of dollars down the road so
people were questioning that and what
Coke does is they get a bunch of
consultants in the room and they have a
Playbook and the Playbook revolves
around how do we rig how do we pay off
how do we weaponize and institutions of
trust okay that's the and it's not that
complicated but I watched as we put
together a list of prominent civil
rights groups and it was very
transactional you go into the NAACP in
this case and there was reporting the
New York Times uh in 2012 Coke paid
millions of dollars under the American
battles Association to the NAACP and the
conversations were shockingly
transactional it's parents are
complaining and worried that their kids
are drinking 100 times more sugar than
they did 100 years ago we need to label
our opponents as racist and keep soda in
food stamps for spending and that's
exactly what the NAACP uh Hispanic
Federation other leading civil rights
groups did and what is their argument
their argument is if you go after the
food stamp programs then you're racist I
think this is really important because
it's not like evil conspiring but it is
like you know kind of a wink wink it's
like hey you know and it's very
patronizing actually it's like hey these
under lower income folks they love their
Coke it's a true read let's not take
that coke away from them you know this
is this is Nanny State it's ironic
because they weaponize conservative
language too Nanny state but what is
being questioned is the fact that
government money is being paid for soda
it's actually in the opposite direction
but it's kind of that language it's like
you know we're trying to tell these
lower income folks what to what to eat
and drink let's not do that you know not
debating whether it's good for those
lower income folks to be having
government subsidized diabetes water uh
not acknowledging the point that a man
in the United States who's at the lower
uh income bracket the lowest income
bracket dies 15 years younger than a man
at the upper income bracket I mean
that's entirely because of nutrition and
the communities are being decimated 25
of children right now have pre-diabetes
and that's disproportionately impacting
lower income communities of color so of
course this is a disastrous policy for
um the groups that are uh professed to
represent but um but yeah that's the
type of language it's we can't take away
choice so weaponizing race is is just a
key part of the Playbook whenever you're
trying to win a debate it's how do we
weaponize and call our opponents racist
that was in The Playbook and why is it
controversial to take the position that
the government shouldn't be buying
non-nutritional food for anyone forget
income brackets but like if we're going
to spend government money then
is it a controversy to say hey it
shouldn't be spent on things that are
going to make people unhealthy which
will then create a draw on the Health
Care system and create other problems
down the road which kind of just puts
the government in this spiral of having
to constantly fund for uh the food and
beverage that people consume which then
leads to them having to pay for their
health care as well
this is obviously the bipartisan issue
of our time I mean we're debating trivia
right now as 25 of kids have
pre-diabetes we talked about 50 of
American adults have pre-diabetes or
diabetes 93 of Americans have some
biomarker of metabolic dysfunction now
what is that what does that mean
metabolic dysfunction diabetes
literally it means cellulose or
malfunctioning diabetes is cellular to
circulation but all of us almost all of
us are on some level of cellular
dysregulation of metabolic dysfunction
and that means the American people are
bodies and brains like are literally
malfunctioning and it you know you tie
it and there's a lot of studies on this
right but 20 of ourselves are in our
brain
um and now 25 of the American people are
on a mental health medication according
to the CDC during covid 25 percent of
teenagers contemplated suicide obesity
autoimmune conditions allergies all
these things the the underlying branch
is cellular dysregulation tied to food
and as you mentioned and as you said we
actually subsidize that not just with
food stamps spending the number one item
that goes to but uh tens of billions of
dollars of subsidies uh crop subsidies
0.4 of subsidies in the United States
for agriculture go to fruits and
vegetables they're considered specialty
crops ninety percent go to Corn which
turns into high fructose corn syrup and
Grains which turn into processed grains
we take the fiber out they're the basis
of our diet now and they turn into sugar
so we're subsidizing these things and
again it's because the food companies
they understandably want to make the
food more addictive when you load it
with sugar load it with processed grains
also inflammatory seed oils which are
subsidized it becomes inflammatory but
also very addictive and cheap
um the Criminal part is the handoff to
Pharma and health care we would expect
the NIH we would expect Stanford and
Harvard Med schools to be be waving the
alarm about why people are sick but the
key thing I think most folks don't
understand is that every institution in
healthcare they make money when there's
interventions on sick people right 95 of
all Healthcare spending is on sick
people is an intervention or a
prescription
so everyone in that system is
incentivized to make money when people
are sick and what's happened is there's
been silence on why people are getting
sick so I've gotta kind of tying this
all together so when I was working for
2011 2012 on the food stamp issue you
know again Coke paid off the civil
rights groups things tanks research
institutions they they processed food uh
gave 11 times more money than the NIH to
nutritional research so the debate was
rigged but the American Medical
Association the American Academy of
Pediatrics medical schools nowhere to be
found completely silent but today
they're being very vocal because just
this year we now have approval and it's
coming online a new obesity drug
intervention okay ozympic semi-glutide
you might have been hearing about this
it's predicted to be the most successful
pharmaceutical product in history
um so right after I would meet with the
food companies you know another the
biggest spender in DC the biggest
spender on this stuff is pharmaceutical
companies and the key thing to
understand is like again everyone in
that room thinks they're they they
justify and they're creating life-saving
drugs but nobody's asking why people are
getting sick they're profiting from
people getting sick so now tied to these
policies like the food stamp like the
subsidies we talked about now as we talk
about over 40 percent of teenagers and
kids are obese or overweight and this
drug the American Academy of Pediatrics
the association that credentials uh and
gives guidelines for all pediatricians
in the country said that every
overweight or obese teenager should have
a weekly injection of this new obesity
Cure All right so hold on a second
the food companies are incentivized to
sell
various types of food and beverages that
obviously are addictive they may say
they're not doing it but obviously
they're doing it
um
what percentage of let's say Coke sales
come from selling sugar water versus
other types of products that they have
do we know that answer Coke it's the
vast majority then PepsiCo has a lot big
food on but Coke is it's increasingly
becoming but it's it's the majority of
their okay yeah and then the
pharmaceutical companies are like hey we
need sick people because that's
ultimately who our customer base is
Right pharmaceutical companies aren't
looking at their Market opportunity map
and saying okay here's the healthy
people let's target them they're saying
no it's the sick people that's who we
need to Target but this idea of an
obesity shot right a weekly shot that
they supposedly want to give to is it
just young people or is it to anyone
that has obesity obesity or overweight
which is up which is getting close to 80
percent of adults so eight uh
potentially up to eighty percent of
adults who are obese or overweight they
want to give a weekly shot to and what
do they claim that the shot will do
well let's get to the Playbook so uh
what the Pharma companies have done what
Novo Nordic the parent company has done
is they made 420 000 I helped
orchestrate this but but this is on the
government website they gave 420 000
unique payments to obesity doctors in
2021 and absolutely flooded The Zone on
donations to the major uh associations
like the American Academy of Pediatrics
also they're the largest funder Farmers
the single largest funder of news so you
had as a perfect storm so a couple weeks
ago you had a 60 Minutes special on
Obesity the doctor Dr Fatima Stanford
from Harvard
uh on that special said that obesity is
genetic she literally said that
your choices and lifestyle and what you
eat and how much movement you have does
not have a large impact on Obesity
what's genetic obesity is a problem in
the past 50 years a Japanese person in
the United States has three times higher
obesity rate than a Japanese person in
Japan
the this doctor from Harvard who has
been funded tens of thousands of dollars
in the past year by this drug company
set on 60 Minutes which is funded by
Pharma before and after the segment
aired there were Pharma ads that obesity
is genetic the next week
this is not a joke so
what did the journalists say when it was
completely legislation just accepted
like it was completely unquestioned the
New York Times the daily podcast ran a
very similar piece recently parents are
listening to this who are suffering and
she is saying that obesity is a genetic
condition and it has to be treated with
Pharmaceuticals and it's an urgent
imperative that parents don't really
question or stigmatize what their kid is
eating but need a pharmaceutical
injection is this also part of the whole
like um uh basically if someone's fat
you have to be accepting of that it goes
into the whole like Dad bod it goes into
the mannequins at the stores and trying
to normalize it and it's this idea that
like if someone's fat you can't say to
them yo you should eat healthy work out
sleep and like generally take care of
yourself and you won't be fat anymore
like that has now become somewhat taboo
to talk about if you go to any nutrition
panel any conference on nutrition the
the buzzword is let's not stigmatize any
food stigmatism that's not stigmatized
it's not stigmatize any food that no
particular food is bad a tower you know
how we're eating it getting back to the
food and again let's just let's again
it's it's it's it's we're getting sick
and then there's profit from that so
let's talk about that
the uh food pyramid right which has
really led to a chronic disease crisis I
think the most deadly public policy
document in American history write the
document and the 90s that said we should
eat more carbs more sugar less healthy
fats which actually doesn't make you fat
um it sounds absolutely absolutely you
can trace the food Paramount which we
all know about to uh trillions of
dollars of of of uh budgetary loss and
millions of lives cut short were lost
that study was directly funded by
Harvard research from the sugar Council
they didn't even try to hide the name
back then the sugar Council which said
sugar doesn't cause obesity and we need
a high carb diet that went into the
dietary guidelines today as I said the
food companies absolutely have a
Stranglehold on nutritional research
there's tens of thousands of nutritional
studies put out every single year God
knows what they say I think it's
actually pretty simple and the
foundational NIH uh Guidance the
millions of dollars funded by the NIH
nutritional study the food compass
uh was also jointly funded by food
companies and says that Lucky Charms are
three times healthier than beef and that
Honey Nut Cheerios are healthier than
eggs and that Cheerios are as good as
quinoa
and it says that orange juice should be
highly encouraged for children which is
again just diabetes water doesn't have
the fiber terrible it says it should be
encouraged uh and and kids can drink
that every day this is a foundational
study that is being used actively right
now funded by the NH to influence
childhood marketing and nutrition
guidelines so you've had this nutrition
ecosystem totally dependent and funded
by food companies saying that there's no
bad foods when are there
people inside of these research
institutions whether they're at
universities or they are kind of
publicly funded things or even private
Research Laboratories
are they dumb are they just bought off
and they're in on the the game or is
somehow are they told hey run a study
this way and it's like stacked against
them and they're just you know kind of
monkeys executing plans like like how is
it that you have worked your entire
career to be a researcher a scientist a
nutritionist or whatever and then you
say with a straight face and put your
name on a document that says that Lucky
Charms are three times healthier than
beef so we all know the system's screwed
and rigged right what I'm really trying
to do and I think is resonating is use
my experience to really paint the
specifics and I actually have a specific
story on this so my life's calling right
now with my partner Justin Mayers we
have a company trying to change food
incentives but we are trying to call
attention to specifics of the rig system
so we are proud that we brought
attention to this lucky charm study it
was released a year ago uh but he wrote
a piece on on Mike Solana's sub stack
and um and I tweet I did went viral my
salon is fantastic he's the man he's the
man so he was pushing it pirate wires
yeah it's it's the best driver and it's
driving and it's driving real uh change
so I'll explain to you how it's actually
I I believe pirate wires I I think it's
actually unquestioned it saved lives in
this case
so the pirate warriors article went
viral I did a tweet that went viral of
that
um Joe Rogan saw it so Joe Rogan posted
about it
um Fox News which is the only Network
that will cover uh anti-farmor stories
which we can get into uh covered at
nightly
um and there was a lot of pressure
okay what I've heard is that there was
active
efforts to have these labels that said
Lucky Charms cheer you know honey chairs
are great on literally packaging
standardized throughout Africa and in
the US and the Rockefeller Foundation
other big funders of this of this study
and the research and the kind of
community because of the pressure
actually stopped that effort to have
these labels saying that these terrible
foods are good because of that pressure
which is great why is the Rockefeller
Foundation or any other Foundation right
in uh that is alleged to be involved in
this stuff why would they want to get
those labels on theirs because they're
investors in the food companies or
something else well let me so so let me
let me get I can get a little bit into
the motivations uh specifically so with
that attention I was contacted by the
lead author of the study
um a guy named uh Darius
um a a doctor
is his first name and he was at Davos
and called me uh pretty upset he said
he's getting uh hundreds of angry emails
to which I applied that 25 of kids have
free diabetes right now because of rig
studies like this and I understand why
people are angry and I'll just go
through and I I dug into these questions
with him and I'll just tell you what he
said
I said you've been paid personal
payments so his studies to close not not
just research funding but personal
payments from a manifold of processed
food companies as many nutrition
researchers get
the study itself was funded by Danone
and other processed food companies
Danone makes almond milk the number one
Dairy item in this study not Greek
yogurt grass-fed it was chocolate almond
milk
chocolate almond milk was the number one
rated Dairy and Danone which is the
chief funded study was the main funder
you can't even make it up I asked in
point blank did does when a group or
company gives you millions of dollars
does he said absolutely not do your
personal payments influence your
research absolutely not I asked him
specifics he said oranges should be
encouraged for children he spent
literally it was comical 15 minutes
explaining why Lucky Charms are not only
magically delicious but also should be
encouraged
what is his art I mean let's just stay
on that for a second what is his
argumentative Lucky Charms uh should be
encouraged for kids I I wouldn't give my
kid Lucky Charms if it was my choice
right obviously kids kids want to eat
stuff right and well they get addicted I
mean their weaponized with sugar in
process yeah and so to some degree like
you don't want to uh not allow your kid
to ever have sugar no matter what or
whatever but I think most parents are
like look I want my kid to be happy but
I also want my kid to be healthy right
and so so if I want my kid to be happy
and healthy I'm not going to feed them
Lucky Charms every day maybe they get it
every once in a while it's kind of like
a treat ice cream whatever right I don't
think you want your kid to live like
they're in like a prison but at the same
time like dude how can you say that you
should encourage kids to eat Lucky
Charms every day
yeah I mean cyber on the on the drug I
agree I'm not you can't be just a total
Zealot with your kids but I think it is
important that just because something's
normalized doesn't mean it's very very
wrong I think doctors used to smoke in
the 60s in their offices and I do think
actually sugar and the fact that it's so
normalized for kids we're going to look
back on with shame I I really do believe
that it's a highly addictive dopamine
trigger I think it's indistinguishable
from many other drugs and it is very
dangerous so I just you know as a new
parent I agree you can't be a zealot but
like it is I think highly problematic
that sugars normalize to the specific
question what he specifically said and
again I am a Tech Pro I'm not a medical
you know professional but you know again
I think I actually have a really good
perspective on this because I saw early
my career on impressive people rigging
the system and I will tell you like you
have grain companies paying him you have
any any reading of the literature or any
just common sense highly processed
grains are an absolute disaster this
shift to highly processed grains which
take out the fiber all the nutritional
value to make the grand shelf say they
don't do this as much in Europe like
they they they're it's outlawed they're
these grains that are sprayed with
Cheerios has so many um pesticides on it
it needs to be differently formulated in
Europe like like these are very very
problematic and he aggressively argued
that these highly processed shell shelf
stable Franken Foods these grains which
are then fortified with it with vitamins
you basically just like in a lab put
some vitamins on are just as good as a
whole grain as quinoa or another whole
grain you know that's natural that
humans are evolutionary created over
hundreds of thousands of years to eat he
said the Fortified processed grains and
I I just think that's just completely
wrong I mean it's not that much
I don't think it's that much of a
stretch to look at what's happening to
the American people to look at what's
happening to health
and trace it to food and it's three
things with food it's highly processed
grains it's sugar which we eating 100
times more of and it's these industrial
seed oils which are highly inflammatory
these are all processed grains were
created just 100 years ago they're new
inventions same with seed oils and added
sugar is basically a new thing in 100
years everything and doctors I think any
doctor would agree with this the the the
underlying theme of disease it's
inflammation why are we chronically
inflamed because we're eating as a
foundation of our diet things that we
are not made to eat these are new
processed inventions so he argued that
that is not the case and that uh grain
highly processed grains Lucky Charms are
okay not even addressing the fact that
it has a lot of added sugar too and I
don't for the life of me understand the
CDC says that a two-year-old it's okay
for 10 of their entire calorie intake to
be sugar like I do not understand why
there is not just a unanimous like like
beating at the table among the nutrition
communities to say that it should be
zero for a small infant but like this is
a good example right so NIH CDC all
these organizations a lot of people uh
probably never even heard of these
places before all of the uh coveted
stuff
um and the whole experience there I
think a lot of people are like ah they
seem to not really kind of understand
all the details there was a lot of uh
waffling back and forth so I think most
of the American public are a lot a large
percentage of them are kind of like I
don't know what's going on over there
but when I hear something like the CDC
or the NIH is saying yeah 10 of an
infant's diet should be sugar and that's
okay literally the question I passed in
my head is like are these people dumb or
are they being malicious or like what's
going on okay hey guys what's going on I
hope that you're enjoying this
conversation but I wanted to interrupt
for a quick second and tell you about a
brand new conference that I'm hosting on
March 4th at the Miami Beach Convention
Center the event is called lyceum Miami
and tickets are completely free for
anyone who wants to come I'm bringing
together many of those most popular
guests from the podcast over the last
couple of years some of the guest
speakers that we've already announced
are people like Vivek ramashwamy from
strive asset management or Delian and
Mike Solana from Founders fund Chris
Williamson from the modern wisdom
podcast Cody Sanchez from contrarian
thinking and billionaire Christian
augermeyer among many others I've got a
number of amazing surprise guests as
well some that you definitely will not
expect and others that come from walks
of life that you will be scratching your
head as to how I even got them to show
up but come check out lyceum Miami on
March 4th the lyceum was a public gym in
Athens Greece where people used to come
together talk about ideas and debate
topics that were important to society I
want to meet people in person in real
life once again after three years of a
Hiatus from real life events and so I'm
hosting the event and as I mentioned
anyone from anywhere can come to this
event completely for free all you need
to do is go to lyceummiami.com and
you'll be able to pick up a free general
admission ticket make sure you claim
your ticket in order to get in through
the doors
lyceum Miami is going to be a great time
so come check it out come hang out with
me many of the popular guests from the
podcast and other like-minded
individuals lyceum Miami March 4th Miami
Beach Convention Center I hope to see
you there all right let's get back into
this conversation
so I was in Texas recently Greg Abbott
has done some great things he was
bragging a speech that the Texas Medical
Center which is now the like I think the
largest hospital in the country can be
seen from space
these things food Health they've become
jobs programs they're Industries right
so it's just not questioned in the case
of nutrition that there's this
multi-billion dollar ecosystem of
nutrition research there's people whose
job is it's at at these institutions
like the Gates Foundation the
Rockefeller Foundation to fund nutrition
research and they have a quota there's
this guy who runs the tough nutrition
school and and as a chair of the the
White House conference on nutrition like
that is his life that is his calling if
there's not nutrition research to do he
doesn't have anything to do so and and
and in his head he is he is thinking
that he's doing right I think he he he's
bragging that he's done 500 purviewed
studies I believe that the greatest lie
the American people are being told is
that what's happening is complicated you
did you know that we need thousands of
nutrition studies if we cut seed oils
cut sugar cut highly processed grains we
are eliminating diabetes Alzheimer's
which is Type 3 diabetes heart disease
obesity I mean like like it's actually
not that complicated how you can
actually structure public policy and
societal change but instead the four
trillion dollars of the Health Care
system and the 6 billion excuse me four
trillion and then Six Trillion of the um
food system it's all incentivized to
make things more complicated so that's
what's happening and I think I think
everyone can kind of tell themselves
their stories right so this this doctor
is getting to the kind of how it all
ties who went on 60 Minutes and said
that obesity is genetic she was
appointed the next week to the FDA
panel to set the nutrition guidelines
for the United States in 2025
the panel at the FDA in 2020
of the academics on that panel had
Direct conflicts of interest either to
food or Pharma companies
so you have this situation right you
have to understand
an NIH panel that decides research
funding or an FDA panel that decides
drug approvals it's not government
bureaucrats that are appointing people
from outside and those people are
allowed to have conflicts when I was
working in this area in uh 2011 2012
opioids were a big deal right and there
was a blue ribbon panel in 2012 from the
NIH on opioid guidelines and they picked
the most prestigious person you could
pick the dean of Stanford med school who
was a pain expert
he established the panel the majority of
that panel has had direct payments from
opioid companies in the past several
years and the year that the dean of
Stanford med school was appointed to
that panel Pfizer which is one of the
largest opiate makers gave him a three
million dollar donation to him
personally or to like to to uh to a
group to to the school to the school so
fi which which is the currency for the
school but made a direct and there was a
ton of opioid funding of Oprah companies
to Stanford that panel recommended which
totally funded you know up and down
bought off by opioid Cumby's recommended
looser opioid standards which has led to
Devastation 90 of overdoses from opioids
today illegal opioids heroin and stuff
it started with a legal prescription
that derived from that panel today
there's obesity panels with this woman
who's paid directly Also let's
understand their incentives pain doctors
have an incentive to describe that's
what grants them patience obesity
doctors now this is a miracle for them a
weekly injection that requires you to
stand up for life that's a lifetime
patient so there's huge financial
conflicts and they're the people that
are appointed to actually make the
guidelines
um and and both for food and for Pharma
so again it's like
it's like we kind of assume these
institutions have our best centers at
heart but even the bureaucrats that are
at the institutions I mean no greater
example than Scott Gottlieb who is the
FDA director right and immediately then
went to Pfizer to the board getting paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars there's
this constant revolving door
um but yeah as a as a consultant for
these companies it's not that
complicated you're creating lists of the
people that could potentially be
appointed to these panels and you're
donating either direct payments which
again 30 million dollars from the
Obesity maker in 2021 we don't know 2022
and then billions of dollars of research
funding guiding where research goes
so I think that enables and that's
really to me
the true Brilliance you could say of the
system is that it takes some of the
smartest and frankly most dedicated
people doctors
nutrition researchers you know
scientists trying to discover new
Therapeutics every one of them feels
like they're doing the right thing
they're saving a patient they're
creating pharmaceutical nobody's asking
why heart disease is exploding why
diabetes why so many people are getting
sick there's zero incentive for anyone
to ask that question because the party's
going and everyone feels like a hero
that they're saving folks and nobody's
calling out and it's actually actively
stigmatized to talk about root causes
like uh diet my sister Casey means the
founder of levels
um you know she was top of her class
Stanford med school at the graduation
for you know when doctors finish med
school they choose between 42
sub-specialties they break the body into
42 areas she focused was focusing her
career on one square millimeter on the
head of neck she was a head and neck
surgeon and when she tried to suggest
nutritional interventions her boss at
the time said don't be a [__] and that
is very much what the culture is and
it's in the invisible hand right it it's
let's be Warriors and serve the people
that are getting sick but nobody is
asking why folks are getting sick
is there a problem if we just made a
rule I don't know who would make the
rule but somehow there was a rule made
that said uh you can't conduct
nutritional research that then is used
to form public policy or uh frankly be
published to public citizens if you are
taking direct payments from these food
companies
like if we you know I've always thought
politicians as an example
when politicians get uh elected I have
seen people suggest that they should
have to wear uh like F1 or Nascar
jackets with all the people who put them
there right just for the logos of the
different companies but I said look it'd
be hilarious I get it right the internet
loves that stuff but actually what
probably what it would be impactful is
if you get elected you are not allowed
to oversee legislation for industries
that put you in office
so just you're not if the Pharma
industry put you in office you can't
weigh in on Pharma issues and what my
guess is what would happen is
immediately there would be a lot less
donating going on and so same thing here
is if we just said look you can't
conduct nutritional research if you're
being funded by any of these companies
that are pushing any sort of food or
beverage from a dietary standpoint one
would there be anybody left to actually
do research and two could we make a
system work in that sense
I mean we're in a pickle here because
Healthcare is the largest and fastest
growing industry in the United States
it's a behemoth like I said with the
governor of Texas it's this jobs program
and in the majority of U.S states the
largest employer is a hospital system
um so think about what that means for
incentives for various lawmakers
unwinding that is existential we're
going to go bankrupt with healthcare
costs they're just growing at an
increasing rate our eyes kind of gloss
over when we talk about health care
costs it's it's stated so much but it's
20 of GDP growing at an increasing rate
faster than any other industry it's
going and it's not slowing down it's
going to be 40 percent of GDP in 15
years and we're all getting sacked uh
sick or fatter more depressed more and
fertile literally like male sperm count
has plummeted PCOS the leading cause of
female and fertility is skyrocketing
like there's something really bad
happening and it's only increasing but
it's this jobs program so unwinding that
unwinding the nutrition research
industrial complex the Pharma industrial
complex the hospital industrial complex
I mean obviously in every city in the
country the biggest most gleaming you
know building as a hospital that's going
to take but but we have to do it but
yeah so as far as public policies I mean
I think the first thing we need to do is
understand these incentives I think the
key to being an empowered patient is
just understanding them and I do think
there's going to be a Bottoms Up
Revolution because the math actually
demands it like and I I think it's being
led by parents who are seeing what's
happening to kids so I think
understanding this I'm a free market guy
like I think Coke Pharma companies
should be able to exist but we should
definitely talk about it right and if I
was if I had a billion dollars I would I
kind of similar to what you said maybe
maybe a little bit more of a free market
so I I would form a pack
and
counteract to any politician all of
their Pharma and food funding
I would I would replace that and
guarantee that they'll be replaced that
funding for life we need to somehow
there's not a pack for diabetic kids
right there's a there's a lot of money
for Pharma there's a lot of money for
food so there needs to be a
counterbalance for politicians uh that's
on the side of diabetic kids and again
if I had billions of dollars I think
that would actually be the highest
leverage thing you could possibly do
because because once you change it's all
about incentives right it's all these
politicians everyone they all have
plausible deniability they all plausible
because they can all say you know oh I'm
doing a nutrition study
um if I had a button I could press it
would eliminate all nutritional research
in the United States the the thing that
we are doing the thing that you know
these academics I don't think the folk
the guy I talked to um who's the lead
research in the country even understands
this you have unimpressive PR Executives
in Washington DC creating a strategy of
donations to nutrition research we don't
even care what the nutrition research
says the fact that there are thousands
of studies is the goal it's it's
confusion it's obfuscation right
um but yeah it's changing the incentives
of uh of the politicians the other thing
I would do getting getting to the
medical school
is a crazy statistic is that today 80 of
medical schools in the United States do
not require one nutrition class like
fundamentally like doctors in the United
States are not trained why people get
sick my sister who who as I said left
medicine and started a metabolic Health
company her out-of-body experience was
five years into residency when she was
doing her third surgery today looking
down at a passed out patient cutting
open their sinuses to relieve
um inflammation of sinuses she had this
out of Body Experience where that
patient had been with her under her
knife like six months before and she had
no idea why they had inflammation she
had literally done hundreds of sinusitis
surgeries and never learned why the
inflammation even occurred a diabetes
doctor could most likely from Harvard
I've talked to them can't even explain
underlying diamonds of what happens with
diabetes literally like they are just
they're it's pharmacology it's what to
prescribe
and um yeah the incentives on the med
school is if I had a billion dollars too
I you know you'd attack the politicians
but more than 50 of medical school
funding somehow touches Pharma the
research the grants it you know every
med school there should be some kind of
fund where it's basically clean money
because the money dictates the
incentives which is pharmacology I saw a
working paper so I don't know how far
through the research process they are
and I'm not a scientist
um but uh I was reading it I can't
remember if it was like on mber or uh
maybe it's BLS or you know one of these
like government organizations uh they
have kind of all their working paper
stuff that I just go and check out
what's on there and there was a study
that was trying to uh really zero in on
what is the impact of kids eating sugar
when they're younger but the impact was
not so much on uh their health it was on
literacy on wealth on all of these other
things in in their uh life and what was
interesting to me was
health is one important piece but when
you say to someone are you healthy or
are you not a lot of people I think
would say yeah I'm healthy right or yeah
I and then they tell you something that
they do that is generally healthy I go
for a walk every day right but they
don't think about it in terms of data
they don't think of like are you
actually overweight are you
um you know doing certain things are you
eating correctly like all that now
if you tell a parent
do this and your kid will be healthy do
this and your kid won't be healthy I
actually don't know how many parents
even understand what healthy is right
but if you say to a parent if you give
your kid sugar they will be poor which
is essentially what this study was
showing was that there was a very
material drop in uh the lifetime
earnings of a kid who has given sugar at
a younger age uh I do think parents
listen to that I do think that parents
want what's best for their kid but they
don't understand so much what health is
or nutrition in terms of they're
probably not that healthy or that
nutritious themselves and so instead if
you can put it into terms of Education
or money all of a sudden they're like
wait wait a second you're telling me
that every time I give my kid sugar it's
making them dumber and and they're going
to make less money over their lifetime
do you think that would actually change
it this is what's this is what's so
criminal why am I actually optimistic
and why it's kind of disappeared in
what's happening right now
people first off want to be healthy they
don't want their kids you know there's
this whole thing oh people are going to
be lazy no 80 of Americans don't want to
be overweight or obese and they don't
want their kids to so I looked it up
December 2022 this study was published
the title uh it's on the nber National
Bureau of economic research and it says
the Sweet Life the long-term effects of
a sugar-rich early childhood and they
claim in um uh kind of the abstract we
show that sugar-rich diet early in life
has large adverse effects on the health
and economic well-being of adults more
than 50 years later excessive sugar
intake early in life led to higher
prevalence of chronic inflammation she's
been talking about diabetes elevated
cholesterol and arthritis it also
decreased post-secondary schooling
having a skilled occupation and
accumulating above median wealth
which feels like that SEC that last
sentence is actually what's going to
hammer home to parents if you say that
having too much sugar is going to
decrease post-secondary schooling having
a skilled occupation and also decrease
the ability to accumulate above median
wealth
all of a sudden parents like oh I never
heard sugar being mentioned in those
terms this is what's so depressing for
right now but why I'm optimistic
people listen to Medical Elites right
when the Surgeon General shamefully late
just as we're late on food but
shamefully late but in the 80s said that
smoking's bad smoking plummeted right
lives were saved when as we talked about
the food pyramid said to eat more carbs
and sugar that's what people did it
increased 20 percent of our diet people
don't want to be sick they don't want
their kids to be sick
and what's happening and I I think I
think what's tragically happened is
these health issues have become
normalized I think another huge lie in
medicine is that our friends like people
in their 20s 30s and 40s are healthy
we've normalized
The Chronic fatigue we've normalized
depression we've normalized anxiety
we've normalized obesity we've
normalized like you literally like my
sister said she would talk to a a a
patient who's on five different
medications you know and and doctors say
oh you're healthy we've normalized all
of you know I think there's 17
prescriptions filled per American per
year you know which obviously there's
some power users there but but but
people don't want to be unhealthy or
watch their kids be obese but they're
really actually following the guidelines
and the incentives right the incentives
are we heavily subsidize crappy food and
then Healthcare kicks in later and we
have leading academics from Harvard
saying that obesity is not a big deal so
if you change it yeah so I have two
other things on this specifically
um I uh was in a rural uh North Carolina
town
um probably two three years ago and uh I
was driving with my wife and uh in this
town there's about three stop lights
maybe four stop light so it's not a
One-Stop light town but it's not a a
city or anything like that and on the
main strip we happen to be at the
furthest end and I just said look up
look around and we look straight down
and it was every fast food chain you
could think of there was Wendy's and
McDonald's and there was Orbeez and
there was uh sheets and there was you
know you just go down the line literally
it was all of them and I said to her I
said right now we wanted to get a
healthy meal in this town where would we
go
outside of going to the grocery store
knowing what to buy and then going home
and cooking it and the conclusion we
came to is like how much of the
nutrition problem in America is actually
a poverty problem it is a lack of access
problem and not just I don't have money
to buy food but hey I gotta work three
jobs to actually have enough money to
live and therefore I'm so tired when I
get home I don't cook healthy food so
you know what McDonald's is pretty cheap
and let me go grab a one dollar burger
and you know stuff that in my mouth
before I go to sleep and do it all over
again tomorrow I I think we need to be
really clear
it's a slight variation what you just
said
we have a rigged system problem so this
idea that there's not enough money to
buy healthy food you know it's just
erroneous right every single thing you
saw on that street this processed food
diet it is that is what bankrupting our
country like a person with type 2
diabetes who's on Medicaid is lower
income you know 35 they're costing the
system millions of dollars you know 99
of people with diabetes have
comorbidities and it's the underlying
Foundation of disease so so so so what
we're doing right when I see that that
row of restaurants what I'm seeing is
food stamp spending which is a big you
know source of the it's 110 billion
dollars as we talked about it's
subsidized to go to those things right I
see grain subsidies and all these
subsidies for that toxic food when
there's no subsidies for vegetables
right I see a medical system that's not
speaking out about that that our cells
are completely under assault right a
medical system that actually wants all
that food to be eaten right you always
have the house principles next to all
those fast food restaurants and fast
foods served within hospitals because
they're profiting so I you know that's
because a lawmaker and various people
who represent these industries actually
are representing people where the
largest jobs are the food and the Pharma
so I see a rig system right I see
folks in those cities or when you go to
a public space and see so many people
clearly unhealthy you know I actually
see people trying but there's the weight
of these incentives just totally and
utterly against them one of the data
points um that I recently uncovered is I
went through and I was trying to break
down the federal government spending
right so with the debt limit debate and
just kind of hey where the hell are
these trillions of dollars going and uh
I want to read you something that I
pulled out of that research where I said
when we look at spending by agency it is
shocking to see spending by the
Department of Health and Human Services
is double the Department of Defense
military spending and the Department of
Homeland Security combined
additionally we spend double the amount
on Social Security compared to the
Department of Education now when you
unpack what is in the Department of
Health and Human Services there's a
whole bunch of stuff right it's not just
this type of stuff but what you see is
that this mandatory spending by the
government which is literally by law it
is mandated that they spend is now
making up 60 of all government spending
and it's not just Health and Human
Services it's not just Department of
Education or whatever but what you're
starting to see is that actually
government spending more and more is
becoming the safety net Social Security
Medicare Medicaid all these different
programs and what I wonder is if you
were able to solve for let's say anyone
under the age of 20 today and you're
able to say you know what we can wave a
magic wand everyone is going to start
eating healthy they're going to start
exercising kind of doing all the right
things food companies you're going to
stay out of this and we're going to
actually give these people super
nutrient dense food that they are going
to stay committed and disciplined
they're going to eat this stuff what
would be the impact 20 30 40 50 years
from now in the difference in the amount
of money the government would have to
spend to take care of these people or
health care companies or pharmaceutical
companies would have to actually spend
to be able to make sure that these
people live anywhere near a normal life
compared to if we allow them to keep
eating what they're eating now it's got
to be a massive number this is radical
right 85 percent of health care costs go
to preventable chronic conditions you
know and again everyone should do their
own research for this but it but it and
it sounds hyperbolic
but a to the 10 killers of Americans
leading killers are directly tied to
food right heart disease if you had that
simple public policy pop
of I would call it thinking about our
precious human capital thinking about
the cells of a child and working to
incentivize the most important lever on
those cells which is the one ton of I
call genetic information that they eat
which is now just totally process
inflammatory crap you're like how do we
actually like as a public policy matter
like on the front end
try to get a human to eat
fuel
that's nourishing that helps you right
that doesn't like lead to inflammation
and pre-diabetes which is highly tied to
depression and other mental health
issues a book just came out called brain
energy which actually very convincingly
ties most brain disorders to metabolic
issues to food it's totally tied what
would that do
think about the impact the human cap
it's just very simple our society is
humans right we are feeding ourselves
right absolute crap as fuel it's showing
itself in the metabolic dysfunction
numbers we've said so we have every
member of society going through life
right with literally malfunctioning
cells that's leading to exploding
healthcare costs I would I just argue
declining happiness yeah and and then
what would it do so what your policy
would do and it it's literally like my
whole argument
we've got to engineer all Health all
food policy to get back to basics to
feed people good food which would
dramatically lower healthcare costs and
curtail the eight of the 10 leading
killers of Americans it would curtail
depression and it would be the most
gasoline you could pour on human capital
of America I mean when a when a person
is overweight that's visible cellular
dysfunction it's literally the glucose
being overloaded in the cell and the
glucose turns into fat because it has
nowhere else to go it's visibly like we
don't use science don't use science come
on what are you talking about like
literally it's okay it's genetic uh we
have
that's what we're [__] talking about
though right is literally like you
immediately to describe obesity you just
went to a scientific understanding of
how glucose can overwhelm a cell and
literally create fat that is ends up on
a human body and somebody else is saying
like no dude it has nothing to do with
their putting in their body it just has
to do with their genetics and there's
nothing they could do about it well the
criminal thing to me going back to you
know people under 20. the criminal thing
to me is like actually
it's a to me a welcome warning sign we
need to look at symptoms as gifts
um if a if a child is obese actually
thank God we can actually see that their
cells are having issues you know the CDC
recently report as well 15 of teenagers
have fatty liver disease this is
something only seen in Alcoholics a lot
of the times that's in thin people you
know the the actually your fat cells you
don't need to get two into the size can
be insulin resistant and you actually
have trouble growing fat they the excess
glucose could be stored other places it
could be stored you know in the brain
and cause this function right it could
be stored in the liver
so 15 percent of kids having a disease
right now that used to be only reserved
for elderly alcoholics right that's a
problem so this is just getting a little
bit into this and why your policy is so
important in really thinking about cells
thinking about food
right now we've siled everything okay
and I and my mom's my big inspiration so
so I was born 12 pounds which is a sign
right there that the mom has some
metabolic dysfunction if you're born
massively overweight the mom probably
has some kind of gestational diet it's
funny you say this because I recently
read this book it's called Uh countdown
yeah how our modern world is threatening
sperm counts altering male and female
reproductive development and imperiling
the future of the human race is written
by uh Shauna Swan and this is one of the
things that she talks about is that uh
you actually start to have an impact on
your child when the child is in the
mother's room in terms not just of
alcohol and things that you know smoking
or whatever that people uh generally
know but literally if you are drinking
Coke if you are eating a bunch of sugary
Foods if you're eating you know poorly
like your kid is getting a negative
impact from your decisions we're passing
on metabolic dysfunction in uterus so
the fact that I was born overweight
showed that my mom and me actually were
born with metabolic dysfunction okay and
that was hand waived by the medical
system oh that's very normal gestational
diabetes take this pill
then a couple years later my mom had
high cholesterol oh this is a rite of
passage for women in their 40s uh here's
a Statin you know no problem
then several years later she has high
fasting glucose oh here's some metformin
um that's a drug one of the most
prescribed drugs in the countries this
is a rite of passage for people your age
you know very normal right right getting
a Stan as a man that's just that's just
normal it's like okay on your way no
flag raised
high blood pressure you know she's on a
number of medications going to her 70s
like anyone
then thinks she's perfectly healthy
never had any warning signs so doctor
and then feels a pain in her chest goes
in gets a scan learns she has stage four
pancreatic cancer and dies 13 days later
and digging into pancreatic cancer
highly tied to metabolic dysfunction and
pre-diabetes which he had
you know we can link lung cancer to
smoking we can just as easily link many
other forms of cancer to food as I
mentioned Alzheimer's kidney disease
Cova deaths obviously diabetes and heart
disease almost everything you can
causally link to the food and what's
tragic about the story I think it's very
relevant to every American is these
little steps along the way are seen as
siled here's a drug I actually my heart
goes out to many of our friends right
and a lot of women right now struggling
with PCOS PCOS literally like like it's
not like a like a link you're pulling
out it is literally metabolic
dysfunction like like it is on the span
of diabetes it's the same thing and
there's almost no women I know who are
struggling with PCOS who are being told
not that that's just something you
should take an estrogen pill for or get
a procedure for but that's a blaring
warning sign that unless you start
having curiosity about the
interconnections in your body and the
interconnections of your cells and
disease that if you don't get that under
control that you're going to have
continued results of metabolic
dysfunction probably leading to an early
death and again there's profitable it's
been profitable to Silo Health that has
been the biggest disaster in health
seeing things in silos seeing things
with a different pill to treat instead
of having curiosity which we've been
robbed of of the interconnectivity of
disease yeah um and that's kind of
that's the mission case in Iran is like
if we can have as a matter of public
policy
just be curious about what's the
underpinning of why we're getting sick
which inevitably leads to shifting to
four trillion dollars we spend in health
care more to subsidizing nutritious food
quite frankly I mean it sounds so simple
but it's literally that like that's
where we need to move policies I see it
with my daughter right is
um
I don't think I understood how unhealthy
so many of the baby foods were they're
just packed with sugar I mean three
ingredients I mentioned it's literally
nuts
um I do think that there's like this
like luxury of time where if you have
time to make Whole Foods for a child
then uh you can obviously help them eat
nutrition uh at a higher dense nutrition
level but
what ends up making me think about is
like when your kid goes to school
they're feeding them all kinds of crazy
stuff right inside of a cafeteria or
whatever and then also you start asking
yourself
is it are we at a point as a society
where there's a trade-off between health
and convenience right or can there
actually be a convenient quick solution
to food whether you're an adult or a
child and it be healthy and what it
seems like the food companies have done
is they said that's not the trade-off
we're willing to actually try to achieve
what we are going to do is we are going
to try to drive convenience and profit
and that ends up being a major problem
here's my theory of change
the system is screwed I actually think
that's an empowering message so what the
first step is the Bottoms Up Revolution
so parents right you you buy like
regulation I got it I think we all get a
sheet from the American Academy of
Pediatrics about childhood diet and the
first thing on there is processed grains
it's like give you give your kids little
puffs
the American Academy of Pediatrics is
paid by Coke when I was working for Coke
turns they paid the American Academy of
Pediatrics millions of dollars in the
American Academy Pediatrics had Coke's
logo on its website
okay so just understanding that Dynamic
my message is this as a parent
first principles
you should have the courage to ask
questions think about what a child ate
10 000 years ago were they eating little
processed grains no they were chewing on
stuff they were chewing on natural food
that is where this needs to start and I
do think there's a revolution happening
with parents so we've got to like resist
frankly I'll just say it what our
pediatricians saying and what a lot of
the medical establishments saying then
we get to more of a public policy the
bottom's up but then we get to the
public policy and I believe that this
idea of convenience and this idea of oh
well you know this this said a lot right
this was said by the the nutrition
research sort of very I find it kind of
patronizing when he said this the poor
people are busy you know that they they
they there's not enough options for them
that's like kneecapping someone and then
it's like they can't right you know
we've kneecapped everyone the incentives
are what they they've created this
system and it's very inconvenient right
now
25 of
teenagers contemplating suicide
45 being obese or overweight that's
leading to massive inconvenience the
entire world view of these kids with
their cellular dysfunction is being
massively degraded 25
of American adults being on a mental
health medication like that's a big
warning there's a lot of inconvenient
things happening here those are small
numbers compared to 85 percent of all
Americans being on a uh obesity or
overweight weekly injection well that's
why they're saying it's going to be the
uh the the best-selling drug ever
and what do they claim that's going to
do
so we can get into the mechanics of
Olympic
and this actually touches I think on
on the Dynamics we were just talking
about on siloing so let's just back up
and then we'll get into this Epic
chronic cure treatments
every chronic cure treatment is
correlated with more of the disease it's
trying to treat the more stats we
prescribe the more heart disease goes up
the more metformin we prescribe the more
diabetes goes up the more ssris is again
most prescribed over the country right
now the more depression suicide go up
the I guarantee you
that the moro's Epic we prescribe the
more obesity is going up why is that
it's because these are not siled things
right they're actually moral hazards you
literally the guidance from the American
Diabetes Association until 2018 was that
if you take diabetes medication as a
diabetic you do not need to worry about
what you're eating you can continue to
eat whatever you want as a diabetic the
guidance on ozympic it's the same thing
but let's think about this you're taking
your insulin you're taking your ozympic
maybe your fasting glucose levels are
going down maybe your weight is going
down because what it does is it messes
with your metabolism your gut it makes
you less hungry if you're still feeding
yourself with inflammatory toxic food if
you're you know feeding horrible gas
into the engine even if it's a little
bit less
you're still your body the fundamental
genetic information the uh the
information you're putting into your
body is bad it's dirty it's poison it's
poison you're still so so 30 less poison
again obesity the LIE is that obesity is
the disease in and of itself obesity is
the warning sign of the underlying
issues so if you're putting 30 Less in
your body but think about what that's
going to do to afford those 45 percent
of kids think about the message that
sends when 60 Minutes the New York Times
is saying okay this is good it's genetic
then the kid loses a little bit of
weight but is still eating terrible food
do you think that's going to end well
right like like that's why right from
the 1960s as is it today in 1960 zero
there weren't chronic disease treatments
it was all acute all medical Miracles
right it was emergency surgical
procedures for childbirth for an
appendicitis for a you know imminent
that you're going to die of a heart
attack uh antibiotics pills that you
went off once you occurred until 1960
there was not a chronic treatment the
birth control was the first one
now it's 95 spending because it's
profitable it's recurring Revenue right
but in the age of chronic treatments
where costs have been skyrocketing right
um we've actually been declining life
expectancy so for the most sustained
period well before covid it's for the
past six years life expectancy America
has been going down that's the longest
and most sustained period since 1860.
right this is unprecedented so in all
these cures life expectancy is going
down so that is the problem with those
epic number one number two is the
opportunity cost right they are pushing
of course for government subsidize
Medicare Medicaid and various other
programs as you said the hsh budget for
spending because this is such a horrible
disease that it's unisolated as they're
telling us
just imagine blue sky there's hundreds
of billions of dollars that they're
predicting of government money that's
going to go to this drug just imagine
blue sky what you could do with that
money imagine that you're an alien that
comes down to earth and looks at what's
happening everyone's fat
everyone's sick with diseases that are
obviously manifestly tied to food right
and imagine that alien was smart and you
gave that alien four trillion dollars
they would never say to continue trying
to get everyone sick and then try to
superficially drug the problem that's
not what anyone this is not obvious what
we have it's totally actually crazy if
an alien came down to earth and had four
they'd subsidize food
they'd invest in regenerative
agriculture they would invest in
programs to teach kids meditation you
know to get control of their brains you
know and understand the trauma that
that's being caused they would invest
you know in they would think about a
child's cells
when
you see this all playing yeah
can we change the existing system or do
we have to build a new one one of the
things in like the Bitcoin world right
is like you're not going to be able to
change the FED you're not going to be
able to change the Legacy Financial
system we got to build a new one from
scratch competition don't try to tear
down what they have just out compete
them in the market what do you think is
uh kind of the solution here do we have
to go build all new food companies that
are healthier that can compete
eventually with Coca-Cola or what yeah I
think I think the math again demands
that there's going to be rapid change so
my investment kind of spent on this is
that by definition something
unsustainable has to change eventually
and I do think of the us we eventually
get there we get there late but we we
are having a robust debate there's a lot
of discussions on podcasts from Joe
Rogan on down really talking about
essentially these core issues so I I
think from an investment perspective you
have to ask uh is the company is a new
company incrementally helping or
augmenting the existing system are they
putting a millennial pink packaging on
Viagra or making a better ux for
electronic medical records for the
existing system like that's where a lot
of money is going right and I think my
spend would be fundamentally if we
believe something unsustainable has to
change eventually there's literally only
one way it's going to change it has to
be trillions of dollars shifting from
Band-Aids once people get sick to things
that actually keep people healthy like
we actually have to change policy
eventually to keep Americans healthy
because the fact that we're getting so
sick is making us uncompetitive country
and it's going to back up the country
like literally it will bankrupt the
country so how do you it's not going to
be more drugs we're actually told by
many leaders that the promise access
that literally the problem with
Healthcare is not enough people have
access to enough drugs that's of course
[__] we have to eventually so I
think there's actually investment
philosophies I think it's why I like
levels giving people more data the bio
wearable Revolution I think that is an
example that in 10 years we're gonna
basically have what there are no said
they were going to do which was actually
a good idea have a full MRI on what's
going on in our body and we're not going
to have to go to the doctors we're like
literally in most in many states right
now a patient isn't legally allowed to
have their medical information we have a
total Silo of what's going on in our
body we know nothing that's going to
change
um you know I think there is a market
demand and more education around food
but you know food companies that are
trying to be healthy are really at a
disadvantage because there's just
hundreds of billions of dollars of
various subsidies going on healthy food
so you know I I think we're slowly
talking about this but I think I think
the the headwinds are going to happen
again it's the bottom up it's podcasts
there's millions of books being sold
millions of people buying BioWare bowls
what are the best books you think for
people to read if they're interested in
this stuff yeah again what I'm trying to
do and if if one person listens to this
it's not getting the answers in this
podcast it's a journey of curiosity for
the interconnections um and you know
just just on wonder for what's going on
in our bodies I think that's the core
Mark Hyman
um he's an investor advisor our company
we're so fortunate and um and that
really got me started so food fix is an
incredible systemic overview of the
Dynamics uh a doctor named Robert lustig
uh two books metabolical and hacking of
the American mind had a profound impact
on me
um those are two places I'd start and
then you can really go down the rabbit
hole
um you know I think you know every
podcasts are talking about huberman I
think a lot of people are listening to
him but it goes into this very well Mark
Hyman has a podcast I honestly think Joe
Rogan is one of the
vanguards of
medicine and the scientific method he's
actually having and scrolling through
his podcast having a lot of doctors on
talking about metabolic health and
actually pursuing the scientific method
of having different views on and asking
questions the number one target of the
medical system from NIH to medical
school is trying to shut him down having
people talking about how food exercises
and looking at the sun maybe we should
do a little bit more incentivize that so
um I just think going down the rabbit
hole and being able to ask questions for
you and your kids is very important and
those authors are a good place to start
what is like your aspiration in terms of
what are you guys trying to do with this
company that you've referenced uh what
is kind of the goal of the business and
like what do you think your contribution
to kind of making these changes either
existential challenge
um that we asked I could give you a
little bit of the story if that's okay
but after my mom kind of abruptly died
um
and uh at the same time you know several
years before my sister leaving the
medical system which was a big family
event I mean she was the pride of the
family in the medical system abruptly
quit because she was so horrified with
what she saw started levels
um and I had sold our previous
e-commerce company think about what I
want to do and and the core idea
I I just can't get out of my mind and
what I'm devoting my life to is changing
the incentives the problem is that every
level of health is incentivized for
people to be sick and that's the
Invisible Hand creating our system we're
all getting sicker for longer periods of
time which is what makes the system
money so a partner Justin mares and I
bonded over that question and we asked
how can we use existing entities to
change incentives
and we really got it into this idea of
of food prescriptions uh is there a way
actually to make food to make exercise
tax-free and we actually found a way so
Mark Hyman and other functional medicine
doctors on a micro level at clinics and
stuff actually are writing food
prescriptions and exercise prescriptions
for patients with metabolic issues that
are not being handled well by the
medical system and if you have a note
from a doctor you can actually use HSA
FSA money these pre-tax accounts that
are very under optimized to buy food and
exercise you need a doctor's note the
HSA FSA accounts most people most your
listeners probably have access to them
Justin me a lot of people never use them
they kind of because it's like oh it's
money the user lose it for when you're
sick we're all sick this is the key we
all should be aggressively we all have
metabolic dysfunction Brewing within us
and it's totally within the spirit and
letter of regulations what is a food uh
prescription and exercise prescription
yeah so so so so our implementation is
we're partnering with exercise companies
food companies you can go on our website
truemad.com or in a payment integration
so just like a firm you'll see it right
when you're buying your supplements when
you're buying your eight sleep
um for instance we're they're investors
and we're chatting with them but
products like that
you'll be able to click on that and
answer a couple asynchronous health
questions
and if you qualify if you're trying to
prevent or reverse a condition we can
approve you right away and you can
actually use your HSA FSA card your
hsafsa funds right in the payment flow
and that's a 30 40 savings you save your
entire income tax
I will put an eight sleep which improves
your you know sleep and there's data on
this I would put broccoli I would put
exercise I would put that against any
pharmaceutical treatment and there's
studies on this that we have backing us
up so we threw the payment flow
integrating with these merchants
which were very rigorous to have a
clinical team improving
um Can enable that spinning so I've
never used my HSA uh FSA but this past
year our family did 7 200 bucks
um and we're going to be able to use
that on food and exercise on things that
keep our family healthy and so what does
the individual contribute into it and
it's basically kind of pre-taxed dollars
go into these yes through your HR
platform the majority of Americans have
access is when you're kind of clicking
through your open enrollment it's one of
those things where like do you want to
contribute and most people just ignore
it there's 140 billion dollars sitting
in the couch right now about 30 40
percent of your listeners probably have
money in there
um but it's at open enrollment so you
click you contribute up to 7 200 for a
family
and that pulls directly from your
paycheck um getting into the weeds here
it's actually kind of cool it's like a
tax-free loan because it you get that
money up front on January 1st and it um
it pulls over the whole course of the
year so it's like a tax-free loan
basically and then you can use it for
health care costs or in this case case
you guys have figured out how to do it
for food and exercises yeah it's very
under optimized I mean there could be
trillions in these accounts there's 150
billion and now most people have access
to them but they're really designed by
Pharma most Healthcare policy is
designed by Pharma and these little
accounts for once you're sick to
basically buy Pharma that's how they're
designed but according to all Health
Care regulate you know how a medical
intervention medicine is something a
doctor denotes to prevent or reverse a
condition and food and exercise are
that's our goal of our company our goal
is to change incentives to put food and
lifestyle habits I mean the four pillars
it's not that complicated but it's food
it's sleep it's movement and it's
management of chronic stress we want to
put that at the center of Health what we
want to show we're building a movement
you know is you can really use your
health care dollars these dollars that
are supposed to go to Pharma for core
root cause issues and we're building a
movement around that which we've been
honored to speak out on what we want to
do is really create that and we're
already engaging with the number of
members of Congress who reach out to us
on this on this campaign you know we're
going on Dan crenshaw's podcast and and
folks on the left too Cory Booker's been
huge on this
um we want to use this as a model of
public policy this is where a public
policy has to go we have to give folks
and this happens in some European
countries we need to incentivize them to
buy doctor-approved healthy food yeah it
um it seems like such a bipartisan issue
right like we want people to be healthy
we want them to be eating uh the right
Foods we want them to generally be uh
metabolically healthy and if they
understand how to do that and they are
doing it they both can pass the
knowledge in kind of a adult to child
relationship but they also can show the
child just through their own actions hey
here's the food we eat here's the type
of exercise we do here's the things that
we do to be healthy and you can similar
to teaching a family personal finance
and change the trajectory of them
financially you could actually teach
them nutrition and exercise you can
change the trajectory of that family for
many generations to come because it gets
passed down from generation to
generation I I I really put it at a
spiritual level I mean somebody asked me
you know what what do we need to do from
a policy perspective what do we need to
do societally to get to really radically
change this I joke you know we should
put psilocybin in the water supply it
but I I'm only half joking I I really do
tie that to this that 25 of folks on on
SS rise we've generally like everything
we incentivize kind of numbs you you
know for for mental health or you know
the food we're eating is really like
taking us away from reality and taking
us away from awe
I really see this just personally
speaking and I I'm sure I know a lot of
your your listeners are on this journey
I think it ties very well into to
bitcoin I mean I think I think the
people this is really resonating on with
Twitter are moms and and people you know
who uh who support Bitcoin I mean I
think it's people that are waking up and
questioning the system but I think like
actually questioning the system actually
having awe and curiosity for
interconnections you know and really
investigating you know what your kid is
eating and how movement you know I I
never thought about exercise until
recently about just like it's not just
for vanity it's it's it's it's it's
understanding that that helps yourselves
I I really do think right the more we
can foster that wonder about the
interconnectivity of our body as a
personal and public policy you know why
aren't we teaching kids about how their
cells work and how food impacts their
cells and how to meditate and why sleep
is important I mean we don't even talk
to people about that
um so it starts at home but it's like I
really do feel and our mission what I
hope to see in the world and what Casey
and I are you know it's it's really
amazing to work on with her on we're
writing a book on this
um is that this becomes
the center of public policy it's just
like thinking about the individual and I
put you know food on that I mean this is
a whole nother podcast but the the
Psychedelic Renaissance I actually think
is a massive societal we've been totally
gaslit on on what a good drug is and
what a bad drug is
um and uh and I I think that's actually
related so yeah where can we send people
to find you on the internet if they want
to learn more yeah so uh we're starting
this company truemad.com
um to specifically very simple value
proposition right to to enable you to if
you're qualified to um to purchase
exercise food certain supplements
tax-free uh so go to trumed.com we're
launching that soon uh have a really
great team of mission based people
who are really excited about that and
about the next 20 years for that
um Cali means on Twitter I've never been
a big Tweeter but you know it's been
it's been amazing you're warming up I'm
warming up yeah and um and and these
these uh topics have resonated so we
actually just for our brand marketing
for our company we just need a lot of
people to know about us that's our kind
of raw business but what Justin I are
doing is we're going to continue
exposing and speaking out about these
issues we're going to hire investigative
journalists we're working with members
of Congress now you know Bill Ackman
retweeted my tweet we're speaking now to
billionaires and prominent lawyers about
organizing a class action lawsuit as our
company kind of brand strategy we're
going to try to continue this Mission
forward of you know kind of on that
level exposing and trying to change the
system from the top down and what we see
through medicine as is changing it from
the bottom up by incentivizing healthier
behaviors I I really do think right if
you can save a family 30 40 percent
on healthy food it's just basic
economics it's basic incentives we need
to do more and more of that so that's
what our company is trying to do so
truemad.com Cali means on Twitter I love
what you guys are doing uh as soon as I
saw the tweets I was like oh boy here we
go so please keep it up and I think
people will not only learned a lot but
uh it's an inspiring mission in terms of
uh wanting people to be healthy and kind
of changing their lives I appreciate
everything you guys are doing and we'll
definitely do it again in the future
well thank you pop for questioning
various systems and um putting amazing
Vibes out there really appreciate you